top gun maverick is one of the most
highly anticipated movies of the year
and with good reason that's true gail
that is true the high flying sequel
follows navy pilot pete mitchell
nicknamed maverick as you might know as
he trains a new generation of pilots for
a very special mission one of them is
called hangman played by actor glenn
powell he previously starred in the
oscar-nominated film hidden figures and
netflix set it up in this clip a very
confident hangman talks to the other
elite pilots about who is going to be
the team leader of this special mission
brad shaw
because i live and breathe
hangman
you look
good
oh i am good rooster
i'm very good in fact
i am too good to be true
so
anybody know what this uh special
detachment is all about now mission's
mission
they don't confront me
what i want to know
who's going to be team leader
and which one he all has what it takes
to follow me
and that's darned that confidence oh my
goodness is is hobbiton calling oh my
goodness
we've all dated a hangout
yes we have go
ahead paramount pictures is obviously
producing this big one which is
like cbs part of the paramount global
family and glenn powell
boy he's joining us this morning but and
you won but i love you
but i love how you call it the
confidence yeah is that what we're
calling it these days what do you want
to call it gail
[Laughter]
and you're right we all know one of
those
definitely yeah
you weren't flying you don't want your
daughter dating yeah yes you don't i
mean you turned this role down when tom
cruise called you initially i did why
and what changed your mind you know i
originally auditioned for miles teller's
role which was the son of goose and then
you know the role wasn't that great on
the page and then i got to sit down with
tom who kind of told me his
approach to making movies he said and i
said uh he goes all right look dude i
know you don't want to do the movie
what kind of career do you want to have
i was like dude you man
he's like
well do you know how i do that i was
like yeah you choose great roles he goes
no i choose great movies and i make the
roles great
and so we got to basically make this
role together which was kind of
a dream come true
yeah tom did tom have an influence on
you and i only asked that because now we
hear that you've actually gone and
gotten your pilot's license was that
something you had thought about doing
ever before i feel like i've always
wanted to get my pilot's license it's
always like on your bucket list but no
it's not it's not unusual
go ahead you've always wanted i mean
it's like something that just like for
me like it's always like that
spontaneous sense of adventure that you
can just like pick up and fly anywhere
anytime
and
because tom put together this flight
program where he literally we were
flying in the extra 300 the uh cessna
the l-39 the 18
we flew in all these different aircraft
and i
pretty much got all the hours i would
need and i knew so much about aviation
that i could just finish it up so those
scenes are actually you
oh yeah we're in the back of real f-18s
this entire movie
were you afraid
there's a couple there's a couple
moments no because the movie i have to
say is amazing i can't wait for america
to see it i can't wait for them to see
you in it but were you were you afraid i
mean it's more to me than just a couple
of moments when we look half the time i
didn't know what i was looking at i just
knew it was very scary it's you know
we're trying to put audiences on like a
serious thrill ride that's why tom was
like hey we gotta shoot this thing for
real there were days in which we were
flying like 50 feet off the ground 500
knots through canyons where i didn't
tell my mom what i was doing that day
but overall i mean we're flying with the
best pilots in the navy so how many jeez
were you i mean because i had gone up in
one yeah i did not do well put it that
way you went up in the back of anything
yeah i did not do well at all with the
thought it's it's it's tough right so
how many did you pass out i didn't pass
out but i was ready to throw up i was
just seven yeah how many did you wait
seven years yeah seven g's
it is you're like in a very small group
of people who have actually gotten to do
that it's like a really it's like not
many people get that right it's it's
hard to describe yeah really i think the
load limit of an 18 is seven and a half
g's yeah um we sometimes push that a
little bit but yeah it's uh yeah it's
you're impressed aren't you i'm very
impressed
no and i've been on jetblue and i love
that
that's my speed
but when you got your pilot's license we
hear that tom surprised you what did he
do yeah so um you know tom was just so
excited because he just loves aviation
he literally shows up to set
in his plane takes off in his playing
awesome he just makes everything look
cool he's tom cruise he's tom cruise
he's a maverick yeah so um
you know that that just sort of love of
aviation just kind of became infectious
so as i was getting my pilot's license
he would follow up with me and be like
hey like you know i hear your cross
country's coming up you're about to do
your solo so whenever i finish my check
ride i got on the ground
somebody walked up and handed me an
envelope
and inside that envelope it said uh
welcome to the skies tom
and it was a certificate for us driving
lessons wow so so yeah now i've started
racing cars so back to tom's question i
love him saying dude what kind of career
do you want what kind of career do you
want dude it's you've been through this
experience yeah and you're on your and
you listen i saw you in great debaters
years ago so as you sit here today what
are you thinking glen pal about your
career honestly i'm just like really
grateful that i've had mentors like
denzel and tom and these people who have
like kind of pushed me to do this thing
i mean like hollywood is a place that
it's a gauntlet and like i didn't know
anybody when i first did this and and
denzel was the one who gave me the
confidence to actually move out to
hollywood in the first place and tom's
been an amazing friend and mentor to
like on on whatever this journey is
after this i feel more confident because
he's been in my life and when you saw
tom cruise in top gun with your dad as a
kid
this influenced the entire career right
yeah it was like you know
watching watching top gun with your dad
is i mean
i i would recommend everybody go watch
this movie with it's such a great you
know uh it's a it's a parental movie
it's a movie that you know if you're if
you're a mother or father it you it
gives you all the feels as you know it's
like all the feels and i
i just feel like watching this movie
with my dad especially like being at the
uk premiere and
watching my dad literally sit with tom
and like joke and like talk movies i was
literally like getting choked up i was
like oh my god just tom's tom's just the
best with my family and uh you know it
feels very full circle for
a movie that kind of kicked started at
all to kind of full circle well glenn
we're going to watch it with the crew
later i think i'm so excited
i'm very excited about it yes i love
that and shout out to your family
because your sister lauren is here she
says you're the greatest brother that
you are the greatest brother because you
include the family and everything and
clearly we we can see that and hear that
and you play a jerk so well it's clearly
acting yeah yeah thank you glenn powell
and congratulations i appreciate you
guys having me on top gun maverick
premieres tomorrow only in theaters and
you've got to see it on the big screen
it's working cannot wait it's worth the
price